so here they're telling us that a is one
negative for the midpoint is three two
and we're trying to find the other end
point B okay since we don't know what
the coordinates of me are let's just
call this X comma Y okay so you're with
me so far
so the thing that we want to remember
here is the midpoint formula is X 1 plus
X 2 divided by 2 and y 1 plus y 2
divided by 2 so when you think of the
midpoint you can think of an average
like if you get an 80% on a test and
100% on a test and you add those
together divided by 2 that's like your
average that gives you a sense of the
middle right so that's a 90% and we're
doing the same thing here we're
averaging the x coordinates of the
endpoints so we add them up and divide
by 2 and that gives us the x coordinate
of the midpoint same thing with the Y's
we add the Y's divided by 2 that gives
us the y coordinate of midpoint so let's
write two equations we've got 1 plus ax
okay which we don't know divided by 2
should give us the x coordinate of the
midpoint same thing with the Y's
negative 4 plus y divided by 2 equals
the y coordinate the midpoint which is 2
now what I'm going to do here is I'm
just going to clear the denominators I'm
gonna multiply the left side by 2 so
that these cancel and the right side by
2 same thing over here I'm going to
multiply the left side by 2 and the
right side by 2 so if we simplify we get
1 plus x equals 6 and negative 4 plus y
equals 4 if I subtract 1 from both sides
you can see that x equals 5 and if I add
4 to both sides because I'm doing the
opposite operation right y equals 8 we
can see that this end point here is
going to be 5 comma 8 now if you're not
convinced you can always test it out 5
plus 1 is 6 divided by 2 is 3 so that
works out 8 plus negative 4 is 4 divided
by 2 is 2 so you can you know verify
after you get the solution real quick
like that but the key is to use the
midpoint formula and use the end point
that you don't know put those as a
variables x and y so I hope this helped
you understand how to work with this
type of problem better subscribe to my
channel
mario's math tutor and youtube channel
and check out some other videos there
and i look forward to helping in the
future ones i'll talk to you soon